welcome everyone look who's here
brought her back baby to play the
greatest game of all time
yeah you have been playing this non-stop
i need to see what it's all about
what i'm here to learn you're hit you
never played minecraft
so when you look at that when you look
at that meatball what is that
what does that tell you use this to look
around oh
well that's my giant meatball this is my
world in minecraft martial am i supposed
to look at
there or here
we have this really awkward setup and
your name is james charles fan because
that's my secret minecraft account
oh no they will know now i'll change it
it's fine wait i thought you had like a
different scene of yourself
yeah i do i'm wearing this uh i'm
wearing this spooky helmet
you look cute you're wearing a you're
wearing a diamond helmet if you press
i think f5 you can change so you see
your son oh that's how you look one
wait that's not what i was wearing i
want my lazy upload
yeah you're wearing diamond armor you
should be happy with it all right
so how do i break stuff don't break
anything nah
stop
relax you told me one button and i'm
pressing yeah you're in creative mode i
don't know how to get you out of it
okay i gotta show you stuff okay so this
is
come over here okay that's my slave i
mean my worker
i pay minimum wage oh so this is uh
this is my automatic farm you come over
here and press this button
yeah he's doing the machinery don't
worry about it the press this button
no just right click on the button b yeah
it starts to farm and if you follow me
here
you know i'm not very fast it's first
time
no you're doing good maybe the farm
isn't that impressive okay what happens
in the farm
it's just like i'm getting stuff follow
me this
is uh council of watershed oh so this is
it
yeah hey hey oh my god no i didn't you
let
council of watersheds i didn't do
anything
get back to work all right quick quick
quick they're cancelled the watershed
thank you oh really
no i don't know okay so i'm building
this like
oh i gotta show you ikea tower follow me
oh my god stop
changing it i am sorry i'm not
look at the ikea tower look at it i
don't have a mouse right now look at the
ikea tower
oh wow
wow so is it the horse
yeah it's the organ that's your that's
your concern what is that
what you want to shoot are you trying to
grieve watersheet
follow me to the meatball i want to go
to the temple okay we'll do our own uh
level in a second i just really want to
show you like what i've been
why you haven't seen me the past it's in
the water that's a creeper
no not bad oh that says squids why are
you so big
what happens if i fall in the water
they'll eat you so don't fall in
really no you can actually breathe in
water because i have this like
thing set up whoa
what are you gonna do to me i don't know
what you wanted to do
i wanted to give him a ride i want him
to keep me in right now
what did they say well you can ride
horses and stuff but now
you can't ride squids mars no one's ever
tried it
i like the thing with minecraft everyone
just thinks you can do different things
all right you should come up over here
yeah and go up there
now ignore the city okay this is uh my
japanese house that i built for sven oh
yeah you can fly because you're in
creative mode
down from there so this is sven
and this is sven's boyfriend and this is
friend's son
why do you want to come down oh shift
yeah
come on that's cute and then there's
oola wait who's oh
i haven't named the song yet i need a
name tag but it's going to be sun sun
no it should be green what are you doing
well everything's judging you right now
let me take you to
do my freak watch people there or wait
what
hey what's that attacking me it's like a
giant oh it's a phantoms hurry up
okay they're so annoying is it not it's
because i haven't slept in the game
these annoying things come from the sky
okay let's go wait i gotta get my trim
back
no it comes back after all okay so wait
wait wait wait
wait that's uh he comes and goes so this
is what the sheep dungeon you press this
it opens up oh that's tower of llama
that's what i like she likes tower i'm
impressed
by minecraft this is it
finally tower let me show you tower
llama oh
no one likes tower alarm gross stuff
it's all right so this is
all the my workers so after they in the
frick dungeon
after they uh they are done freaking
they i release them hearing hey guys
you're free
i activated my own tribe by accident
okay look
cat i'm here i'm looking nothing is
happening okay okay
look look look at him
and what do they know and then i send
them up for the thing
they go to work it's great oh oh
there he is do you want to try it you
can try it go and try
like a shirt he got hurt he's fine he's
fine what do you mean go in the chat
right huh yeah
yeah going to trap i didn't mean to the
trap is too good she can't find it it's
it's uh
i'm here that's not that it's not the
trap you walk next to it
it doesn't matter hey yeah
oh look you're one of the workers
what job do you want
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can be whatever you want
mother that's so cute okay well that
that's it then
wow why is he doing in my bed
get out felix
is my bed you're not gamers
good night gamers alright we should play
our own world though okay what should we
name our seed
it should be called like if we had a
sanctuary what would it be called
pug land yes can you get past
otherwise that would be very
underwhelming so i'm creating a new
world for us
this is going to be our world but now no
more fun and games marzia
we have to survive no fun let's go we
have to serve
let's go oh my god
don't do any sheets can we make ships
into pugs
someone do that please for us oh here we
are martia
oh you're so kawaii look you have lazy
outfit now
why am i looking back are you having fun
there what are you doing
what are you looking at
[Music]
all right we have to survive this is
important oh my god there's
jurgens no no no no no no everything you
know you're james charles fan you can't
talk to me
also these are not even they're donkeys
look at baby donkeys so cute
cute okay so what do we do well
okay so we ride this horse you can get
on it if you right click it but it will
kick you off because you need to tame it
okay what it looks like you're doing
more than team
rightly does not work look i can get ow
did you just hit me oh i'm in it you're
in it
oh yeah you did you didn't push me down
he
totally just pushed you out down but
okay what about these
you can't ride the sheep as far as i
know you can do other things
what is that what freak is that yeah
that's a mountain
so the world is completely like random
randomly made so this is our world
night will come though i see if you look
in the sky so we need to make our first
home
can it be in the water yeah yeah so if
you follow me
the first thing you do in minecraft is
cut down a tree with your bare fists
to get some wood so pick a pick a tree
that you hate and just start
punching it these are cute you're gonna
ruin everything
well we can replant the trees which one
are you going for
so you just hold you just hold down that
button and you see it start decreasing
yeah you're you got your first block in
minecraft excuse me i don't think that
sounds
yeah that's how they work that's how the
signs work knox made this game
he decides if you press e
you get like your inventory
okay okay after you and then you have
like this crafting area right
so do i bring the blocks yeah yeah if
you bring the blocks there you can make
them into
wood with more wooden like planks or
whatever so you just right
right click there yeah yeah and then
place them in
your inventory and then you have more
and then now you can make other things
so this is like log and now it's like
planks
and then you take the planks to make
other things for example if you grab
more yeah you can do that and then you
place
one right click in there and then click
left click in the different spaces if
you place one in each
uh thing you make a workbench which
maybe isn't that important or orange
sticks sticks are good too
okay yeah it makes sticks and i'll make
a workbench
wait is that all we have to do now no we
have to make a
break well well we can make an axe so
you can break stuff faster
so if you give me your sticks i can make
you an axe
all right i'll make you an axe anyway
[Music]
you click on the crafting table and you
make this pattern you know i don't speak
one
well i can tell maybe if you watch my
lunch place
there you go there you go she's making
workbench next up you'll make a
cobblestone generator
so do i need more sticks i think you
have enough sticks
okay so come over uh come over to your
boy hello
stop don't punch me you know i have an
axe right
wow wow guys you heard me i'm
only saying that you need an axe too
we're gonna build a house marzia
is that mushrooms don't eat the
mushrooms why not
how do i even get there you are they're
poison mushrooms are you sure
no they're not you can make mushrooms
too if you want might say we have to
build a house
zombies are coming at night i'm working
here grab these
grab that axe i give you an x just keep
chopping can i take it
uh yes chop wood marzia at shop shop you
have to say very impressive
how far out reach right yeah
yeah you break faster if you say shop
okay once we get enough wood we should
pick a spot
no they can drop like apples it might be
good to have a little snack you know
i was just gonna murder one of the cows
look you don't stick
what did you say no house murder nothing
what
i would never do not do not are we doing
a vegan let's play
of course but then we have to it's so
much harder
so what just killed the cow all right
we're eating mushroom we're eating
mushroom tonight gamers
yeah okay i think we have enough wood i
think what we can do now is we can find
like a nice spot where we want to build
our house
so should it be high up high up or under
water or whatever you want
underwater okay maybe not underwater
that's a good idea but
what about yeah okay i like that i like
that
see this is where you go are you going
up follow me
okay i'll follow you i see i see so long
yeah i see
so 200 part uh let's play incoming
pewdiepie and james charles fan
do you like james charles why are you
putting me on the spot
whoa no i don't i don't like the
mountains you don't like this is
so cool no this is incredible
no i would rather have the house
all right you pick a spot wherever you
want in the middle of the trees but
it doesn't work if you're gonna break
them i'm not we can replant trees
there's flower biome here here that's
really here
there's biome here okay you're using an
axe to
cut down pp which is not very efficient
so here you go
use this for the dirt stuff
and use this pickaxe to cut down the
gray stuff
you're doing good yeah but it's gonna
get dark yeah yeah but here use this one
a second this one is quicker
i made a better one for you if it gets
dark we can lit up this place oh my god
it's getting dark real fast marzia yeah
exactly
oh my god dig quicker marzia it's
getting darker
i'll make torch are you blind oh my god
there we go what should we name our home
potato i like that we should build a
giant potato that should have been
potato land
ah and then we only grow potatoes
wait what are you doing i'm helping you
excuse me oh sorry
so sorry i'll be right back if i die
marzia just know
what if i'm dying just know that that is
daddy dead are you abandoning me i'm
just gonna
she's gonna disappear for like 40
minutes uh
no it's just in the middle of the night
i'm coming back i'm coming back we just
don't have any food
where's the hole oh here we go
you picked the you picked a good home
yeah i did this
so now we can put uh so evil people
don't come in
put a door here perfect is that a door
[Music]
okay how about this and then put the
door here
that's good i like this i thought it
would look good together it's like using
different
you know what never mind i want like a
big door that's
just yeah they don't have those they
don't have big doors
in this game careful but make a door
make a door i did
what do you think here can you make
windows
yes because i want to keep them the
natural effect that's right yeah
you can make one of those how's this
that's wow that's nice yeah
yeah but what about the door and we can
have a little little
oh cute like decking here so fast
how many years of minecraft experience
this year yeah
so let me see the whole front bar dude
this hole is like the nice
oh it's so cozy it is kind of cozy
don't break too if we murder a couple of
sheeps we can
use their wool to make beds and we can
sleep sleep
why do we need to murder them oh we
don't have to murder anyone of course
i guess i'll make a mushroom stew
instead because we're poor and marseille
wants to be poor can we
make some more lights for back here yeah
here i'll give you some torches so you
can place them
hey wait watch this i've never done this
before
that's so cool
i have to dig hole in can you move it
you're burning
dang it can the ceiling be a little
higher you're a very demanding lady
but of course of course here it is
you're my minecraft girlfriend i do
anything how do i
place the torch uh right right click
there you go so anything any block you
have you can replace
i gotta say this is a nice hole
yeah i think when do we need to eat uh
you see
why do you have so much food why am i
dying and you're not are you still in
creative mood no
i'll make a mushroom stew i guess can
you collect fish
oh the puffer fish someone you said that
you couldn't have puffer fish
yeah yeah but then i need to kill some
enemies enemies
i need to kill spiders spiders
what about chickens no no chickens no do
you want to head out then
are we not going to die no we don't die
maybe i should make a sword actually
then what do you think
he's cleaning up okay here's zombie i
protect you marzia don't worry
i want to kill you here take the sword
[Music]
ah behind me there's a baby killing me
kill the baby marcia
it's fast yeah i hate them oh my god
please kill it
it's gonna it's gonna kill me oh thank
god
you'll learn just tell me where's my
sword uh
it's probably in your inventory i really
want to kill the cows marzia
fine no i won't do it
oh my god i thought that was you
i almost died oh careful
what is that
which which how do i hit are you kidding
me you hit
you hit with this one and you wait for
the sword to charge up
you look like you've taken a couple uh
punches there do i lose things first
[Laughter]
you okay follow me
okay all right i don't know
oh it's full of people there's so many
people
where did you go i'm in the water oh my
god you're so far away
yeah because there are people here i'm
running
how did this happen the sun is coming
back
the sun is back okay that means the
zombies die when the sun comes up just
keep
living yeah keep living for me marcia
and the
animals how big is use a map
well are these crocodiles i don't think
there are crocodiles in minecraft
these are so pretty can we collect these
the fishes yeah you can use a bucket
do i have one no we just started martial
one step at a time
can i do anything to it uh you can hit
it with the act killing it
oh something is killing me oh you
drowned
no yeah what are you doing
at that fishes oh my god i'm going to
die too
well you'll you can respawn ah wait so
what's the problem
you just lose your items but it's okay
no it's not okay oh we have a traitor
here
look at that one oh my god the llamas
are gonna kill me
oh my god i got killed by llamas don't
tell anyone okay where do we meet uh
i'll find you in one second i can come
back i was surprised
no hey hey what are you doing nothing i
just killed it i killed the trader and i
have a present for you
so where was our home uh it was farther
north
so where are you right now i'm coming to
the hall you're coming to the hole
where do you think where is it uh
there we go i see you i see you we'll
stay in the water
there you go there you are here is there
hey marcia you must be so scared
hello i have a present for you marcia
how do i take it you have it follow me
my dad this is our hole
that was close you are close we can all
i have a lead now so we can all
also take hostages like this uh chicken
can come with us and be our house pet
i'll call it a pasta
but we kidnap it you don't want to check
in yeah i will my
brother doesn't want you sorry he says
he has nowhere else to go his family
abandoned him
he says please maybe one day marcia will
change
her mind about me maybe
he says he loves your youtube channel
fake fan fake fan
okay so what do we do how do i get stuff
back um
give me the wood oh wait i can't break
it right i can make it some
beef
it fell on the ground uh-huh it fell on
the ground in front of me look i make
flower in front of my house
i'm tired of being hungry i'm starved
i'm literally starving
there was a cow and nothing totally no
cow
the cow had to go i'm sorry you need a
spider
i don't eat a spider why not all right
so what do you want i can make you a
wooden sword
what do you want anything you want like
anything you want
anything make me a cow i'll make you a
cow is that snow
yes do you want to go there do i find
more stuff yes damn you you're you have
good intuition
uh how do i go how do i go uh where are
you
okay you keep disappearing everywhere
what are you doing i leave you for two
seconds
two seconds you promised more snow
this is not bad you want more snow i
want a house
you want a house full of snow you want
to eat glue beautiful
look at that yeah by the way
yeah let's change it yeah look at these
mountains they're so awesome
aren't you your feet cold so marzia you
wanted more snow
um
here here okay so you can make snow
blocks
let me see i don't remember you use a
shovel
so here use the shovel to get this now
whoa so we should have a location in
every place so like the hole
is in the void
yeah you can go as tall as you want so
wanting the clowns
yeah i never thought of that i should do
that on my own no
no no why not it can be playing so hard
how do you how do you what do you want
to do i want to make any glue but how do
you design
how do you actually use it oh you need
you need me
to help you out okay okay okay let's
just make like a
cube and call it an igloo i would make
it a little bigger
that would make it like bing bang but
there is no floor
and i'll make it a little lower and then
i would make a little um
yeah and then leave one open
so we can see the skies and stuff
hey james charles fan here you go more
we don't have a lot of time i just have
zombies coming soon soon chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop
nah don't panic don't panic you'll be
fine you'll be fine how do we close it
up
is that a round thing um i would
like get on top of it and then i would
put one more up
and then like maybe like that you see
what i'm saying
oh god there we have a visitor emergency
where is he
oh he's outside our house no go away
i'll push him off the moon
did you put this here okay you can take
it off
look at our beautiful eagles look at
that thing marcia
it's a beauty a truly a spectacle to be
observed
it's lovely what matters is the inside
all right what else do you want
it's not on the ground and the ceiling
isn't over
the ceiling isn't over
you
yeah and then i want a bridge to go
what a bridge
here out you can put the fence if you
want
here the fence what
why why did i there i'm trying over here
all right i'm doing the bridge
building a bridge for you marzia how is
this
possible this is minecraft you build
bridges oh god it's so far
no that is actually not bad
i never built anything in snow before we
should uh we should find a hostage
dogs do you have any bones i have a dog
bone we contain one
i don't think he liked it we tame him
he's ours now
oh hello this one or the other one uh
this one
is he tamed i can't tell do you want a
flower give him pleasure
i need to cook the food maybe
don't punch him how do you get it he's
going to kill your majesty
you're sorry my set
why did you attack him he wasn't given
the flower
you were trying to give him a flower
good job all right well
guess it's just me and sven too now
thank you for joining marzia smash like
subscribe
hundred million merch
[Applause]
cool all right what you haven't tried
tuber simulator seriously
after 50 million outros
maya
still relevant just download it